I'm governor bobby jindal and I'm here
to take on the issues through push-ups
coming to you live from the BuzzFeed
studios in the Big Apple we are just
moments away from putting politics to
the push of man Governor Bobby Jindal in
the building ready to go let's see who
he's up against taxes his first foe the
governor's not a fan but if you don't
pay him you go to prison you could ask
Wesley Snipes Obamacare coming off a
huge win at the Supreme Court early this
year this battle is one to watch the
governor has said countless times that
he's tired of hyphenated Americans
definitely no love lost here and of
course the fiercest challenger today
Governor Jindal very own 2009 State of
the Union response speech these two have
a history and it's not pretty
now we're talking a lot today about 2009
State of the Union response speech
because it was a tough one now do you
think you're overlooking Obamacare and
taxes today but these are tough
competitors stronger the taxes yet the
less freedom we all have so you can't
overlook how to one of these two Wow you
heard that here first so we're gonna get
right to the competition are you ready
do you need anything like some gym
clothes I'm good to go let's go we're
good to go
let's put politics and push-ups to the
test
competitors down on your mats ready get
set and go
[Music]
taxes is down not a strong showing but
hey we'll see you next April
[Applause]
and hyphenated Americans hit the mat
looks like the governor is right we are
all just Americans at least for today
Obamacare is out incredible absolutely
shocking
Governor Jindal rolling back landmark
legislation in under 30 push-ups
two longtime rivals mano-a-mano
neck-and-neck neither wants to give in
neither want to show any weakness
what an effort from these two
competitors with every push a grudging
respect growing between them
incredible the State of the Union
response is pushing gentle to keep going
State of the Union response asking just
one more push up from the governor just
one more
[Applause]
I think we can finally put this behind
us I think America won
[Music]